meagan Markel and Prince Harry sent
Prince George a sweet message on his
birthday monday marks the eldest
Cambridge kiddos sixth birthday and
everyone is celebrating heat Middleton
and Prince William took to Instagram a
day early with three adorable new photos
of George - pics show the tiny royal
posing in a Kensington Palace garden
while the third photo was snapped during
a Cambridge family holiday tons of fans
left birthday messages for George
including aunty Megan and uncle Harry
who commented quote happy birthday
wishing you a very special day and lots
of love it's worth noting the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex didn't mention
George's meme or title in their message
one reason for this could be the
backlash they faced over their birthday
wishes for George's sister Charlotte
back in May in similar fashion making an
Harry commented on a series of photos
the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge posted
in honor of their daughter's fourth
birthday riding happy birthday Charlotte
lots of love H&M XL the couple was
criticized for omitting her princess
title with some calling it inappropriate
but here's the thing Megan and Harry's
birthday post for Louie was no different
the couple celebrated his first birthday
on April 23rd with this simple message
quote happy birthday Louis sending lots
of love from both of us excel at least
the Sussex duo seems to be keeping
things consistent we're a fantastic team
we know real
you
[Music]